hello I'm Victoria I work in several
medical we do medical imaging with deep
learning actually do search for
pathologies in cities and x-rays using a
different algorithm of classification
segmentation and we use games as well so
today I will talk about the narrative
adversarial networks young laocoon which
is a big name in deep learning at all
that ganz is the most interesting idea
in the last 10 years in machine learning
why is it so so today I will explain how
gangs work and show a lot of examples I
would like to start with a more
traditional application of deep learning
with classification to teach a network
to classify animals for example we need
to show it a lot of examples of dogs
cats rabbits and so on and to say that
it's a dog it's rabbit and then after
the network is trained we can show it an
image of a cat that for example which
has never seen before and it will tell
it jealous that the most probably this
is kept in crucification a neural
network learns a function that maps an
input data to some desired output class
so if we show that an image of an animal
itself which class it is but what is a
want to get images similar to a given
image or if what if you want to turn on
to convert a brunette in the blonde or
to screen an image from a word
description within natural languages all
this we can we'll do with generative
editorial networks what gans do is
actually create an image from an input
vector of
and the numbers isn't it magic so let us
try to understand how they work we can
look from neligan's example of two
players
counterfeit fetters and police
counterfeiter they produce fake money
and their goal is to create money as
realistic as possible in such a way that
police cannot distinguish them from real
money and in such a way two parts to
gamers compete against each other and
this in gas generator and discriminator
do this these are two neural networks
that play a zero-sum game generator
generates fake samples and its aim to
generate every sample as much realistic
as possible in such a way that the
discriminator cannot distinguish it from
real so schematically this looks so the
generator get an vector of our input of
a noise actually of random numbers and
generate some images discriminator get a
receives either fake fake image or real
image if it's a received fake image and
in it can say that it's fake it's not
real it doesn't look like real so it
tells the generator no you you should
try better and it gives its feedback to
the generator it sends a message it's
called a back propagation and then
generator can improve its ability to
create fake samples in such a way that
after many iteration like the
this generator creates start to create
images that discriminator cannot
discrete distinguish from the real one
and then in the inference time we can
give fit a generator a vector of random
nine numbers and it will create an image
for us it will be these images I will be
similar to the images that it was
trained on for example if our training
set is images of faces of celebs so we
will get images of faces but it won't be
similar to any image in the given
training set so other images real or
fake does it look real yeah it's
actually this article it's from five
days ago ganz is a very new field it
just it was invented but Ian Goodfellow
in 2014 and since then ganz improved a
lot and so these are these are the faces
that were created two years ago and this
is just five days ago so it is the
difference and so let us look into the
systems into the networks so as I told
again a generic adversarial network
consists of two networks the
discriminator and generate discriminator
consists of many of several layers of
convolutional of convolutional layers
and the generator consists of several
layers of the convolution i will shortly
explain now what is convolution and then
called the convolution for to create a
convolutional layer you look at the
input layer and you
we'll run a sliding window iterate over
each cell in the prayer in the input
layer you in every window you multiply
these by weight matrix and some and in
such a way you create the unit every
cell in the output layer the output and
in conventional layers output is usually
smaller or equal to the input in the the
convolution or in other words fractional
convolution sorry output is larger than
the input it's actually the opposite
operation to convolution so in
fractional evolution we blow the input
layer we add some air and then do the
same operation as in the convolution so
we iterate sliding window over every
cell multiplied by great magics and some
so the weight matrix that we multiply it
these are the parameters of the network
that are that we learn with the network
learns and it learns how to obtain an
input image to a higher resolution this
is an example of a generator or in terms
of flow so this we see here is the
generator I remind you it accepts a
vector of random numbers this is Z it's
just a vector of 100 numbers from a
drone from Gaussian distribution then it
is converted projected and received into
a three-dimensional layer fully
connected and when for subsequent
convolutions in the jungle pho is just
this
simple just write a convolution batch
normalization rectified linear units I
will not explain what it is before the
course I don't have time but if you're
interested you can read and
discriminator
it's a remind what we saw that it
accepts it receives an image either real
one or a fake and it should tell whether
it's fake or real
so if input is an image it's in this
again it's a 64 by 64 RGB image and the
output is just one number from 0 to 1 is
the probability and a 0 it means that
the image is fake and 1 the image is
real
so and if it's not fake if it receives a
fake image and it outputs a probability
less than 1 then the its sense to the
generator a message that propagates the
gradient that it's not it's not real
improve yourself so are these images
real fake so these are generated images
this is also a new type of scam but
bathrooms better sign gun which
generates such a beautiful beautiful
bedrooms these bedrooms this generator
was trained on many images tens of
thousands of images of bedrooms and then
it generates bedrooms which are not
similar to any in the training set when
you train a generator you use somehow
the weights on the estimator or say
completely dependent you are ways in the
discriminator and engine generator
they learn every iteration they they
load
the relationship between the literal two
completely independent network they are
computer completely independent
the only dependence is that generator
sent to their loss if you're familiar
with the launch function of loss
function of a generator is - loss
function that of the general
welcome to of generator is - the loss
function of discriminator so if a
discriminator makes a mistake then the
loss function of generator is non-zero
and it's actually has a nonzero gradient
and it's back propagates to the weight
and it proves the weight so later it
turns out that these this vector of
random numbers we can do some
interesting things with it so for
example we can take two vectors to the
vectors of these two images on the edges
v1 and v2 and we can interpolate between
v1 and v2 and the received the vectors
we can again input fit to the generator
and the images that we get will look
like this
so actually what happens is that winter
will interpolate between one bedroom and
another bedroom another interesting
application of is phases arithmetic so
again we take a C vector that generate
this image of men with glasses and we
take a true vector of men without
glasses and subscribe them and add the
vector of a woman without glasses and
what we get is a woman with the vector
that generates images of a woman with
glasses and the
and in such a way for example we can do
also with smiling woman or so what we
should do is just to change this man
with glasses to a smiling man yes yes it
is not not completely understood how
white works but what actually happens is
that a generator it learns the the Joint
Distribution of of the V vectors and the
labels which have faked the real images
and then it can it can from the input
input layer the vector can generate
samples from the distribution of 100
numbers just yes it's I don't think that
it's convex position usually neural
networks are not contacts
yes but neural networks are usually they
are not not convex so it's a gradient
descent like it works on neural networks
but also nobody cannot can explain
actually why it works because they're
not know there's no proof yes but it
works likely so in general the field of
deep learning is more trial and error so
there is another variation of gap called
conditional gamma so here in addition to
the V vector a generator and a
discriminator receives another vector
for example a sentence embedded of a
sentence or it can be also an image and
in such a way we can generate an image
from a sentence for example this bird is
red and brown in color with a stubby
beak or this bird is short and stubby
with yellow on its body and you see the
generator generates images that similar
to the description or the same with
flowers this flower has petals and a
white and has been shading see here pink
or we could also constraint a network to
generate a bird in this in this area or
agent to generate a bird with a belly in
this point and also from a description
of a sentence probably some of them
heard about picks two peaks it's a it's
also a pretty new article and the
demonstration also you can look for this
in on Google picks depicts and you can
create your own bags cats and so on so
what
what you can do is just draw a sketch of
a back click process and it will
generate a back a realistic looking back
or you can draw a cap and it will fill
it with cat texture so here for example
it thinks that it has a third eye
instead of a nose so again again does
not it doesn't know to produce a cat it
knows it's a lot of examples of cats
it was told by the discriminator that
the generated examples are similar to
catch but if you draw some [ __ ] cat
it will still feel it with the cat
structure texture yes yes exactly
it's another example on fix two pigs I
don't show it here where you can draw a
building there's some buildings with
windows and doors and it will be it will
feel it the building texture of yes so
if you see the the images are pretty
detailed but it's small images and the
Gantt all the time improve so with time
probably it will be more and more the
sharp images yes yes exactly
so these are live cam Network and these
are two separate gun networks because
guns can produce can generate images
only from the distribution of of
training set that what they saw what
they were trained on therefore this gun
was trained only on different shapes of
bags
it was trained to get a sketch of a
death and to feel it will back texture
and the same for cats
you will see yes yeah if you draw this
cat on the back Network you will see a
cat back with kept texture I look at
with eyes and the yeah for sorry
probably it's nice to try fairy back
with ice okay so this is another
application in my company so what we do
we can you can draw a skull shape of
scalp and it will the generator will
fill it with the texture of the brain
texture from CT brain city and we use it
for data augmentation actually for brain
bleeds there is no brain bleed here but
we can we can train at own cities with
brain bleeds and then generate images of
brain bleed this is another gun which
shows also that we can convert a certain
woman to a blonde or we can add glasses
or we can make your smile we can also
convert a thermal image into RGB image
or another application is to color a
black and white image or if you want if
you have a back and you would choose in
the same style you can do it or if you
have a car and you want to generate a
face at the same angle so and what they
maybe think that again is not told that
this is the angle in a car in a car and
this is an angle of the face where it
looks too but it was given a lot of all
the test set of cars training set of
cars and
in set of faces and a look in a
different angle and it's understood by
itself that this is the feature which is
common to both sets and therefore if you
give it a car with certain angle it will
generate a face that is in this the same
angle yes yeah I I know there are a lot
of applications now in different fields
in NLP and video and but about music I
haven't heard yet so maybe I agree yeah
III don't know there's another network
by Google who generates which generates
music but probably not games so if you
have horses and you want zebras or on on
opposite if you have zebras and you want
to get horses or if you have an image a
picture a photo and you want create from
this a painting of Monet of invoke
horses an awesome you can do it with
Gamzee yes oh maybe yes we can train
against to the cricket and another
application of Gans is for improving
resolution so this is an example of this
original image and this is the image of
which is improved by get with against
and these are other methods and you see
that the image improved with Gans is
very similar to the original image also
Gans
can be used to improve semantic
segmentation this an input image of a
cow in the field is a ground truth
segmentation this is a semantic
accommodation Network and the output
and when we add adversarial again so we
see that it seems more it looks more
realistic more realistic without all
these dots and another exciting
application of games is for next frame
prediction so this is a video of this is
ground truth this is now ground truth
and these are these frames are
prediction by gun this the prediction
there are four frames that are predicted
so this is a corresponding this is the
corresponding ground truth and this is
prediction now always so in summary we
saw the gans can create very realistic
sharp images and they all the time
improve so intense there is a very
intensive research in this field and
like almost everybody in this deeper
learning now afghans to improve their
networks and but there yet many
unexplored applications of gamma if you
want to read more about again so there
is a nice block of in that against and
where to find them or if you want to
learn some deep deep learning deeper so
there's a very good sanford course
convolutional neural networks or
academic course which has a very nice
introduction to into tender flow and
there is a new book by ion good fellow
and bender on deep learning
[Applause]
yes so we use we have several uses of
Gans as I mentioned we use it for data
augmentation since second a tagging of
data
manual tagging very geologists is very
expensive
so for example we have cities of brain
bleeds but we want more because in deep
in deploying more than we have it's
better and actually what we do we train
again on this city images with bleeds
and then the gap gap can generate images
with bleeds similar to to the training
images but not the same and this means
that we have a commentation date
augmentation and another use is for
improving of segmentation of for example
brain bleeds or CT on pathologies in
lumps yes for segmentation so there was
a network for segmentation similar to
unit if you know for example and we add
again in addition so this unit is a
generator and we add discriminator which
is just a bunch of convolutional layers
that was similar to what is showed here
it accepts an image and it outputs one
number and this the discriminator gets
the segmented image segmentation mask
but the generated outputs and it
receives also the regional image and it
should tell whether it's rake the fake
real and if it's a if it's fake but it
just community doesn't believe that it's
fake so it sends message to to the
generator and image improves itself
yeah for segmentation so it improves its
there is actually paper which shows that
the improvement is approximately three
percent effect in accuracy no we don't
use variation auto-encoders it's a so
people before again tried a lot to use
encoders and variational autoencoders to
generate images and but it it doesn't
work so so well with encode autoencoders
because it's a output it generates
blurry images and as many fields many
things in deep learning you don't know
exactly why first of all it creates a it
does approximation to the Joint
Distribution variational decoders and
again most probably it long the exact
Joint Distribution not the approximation
yes
because what I showed for example with
the cow so this is what segmentation
network outputs it's a it does some
pretty good segmentation but it's still
if you see this would you say that it's
real
segmentation probably not this is what
discriminator does he looks at it and
they say no I don't believe that it's
real and therefore it helps the
generator to to generate better images
yes yes yeah it's a pretty big problem
in the camp to measure how good they are
to quantitatively measure and what
people do many times they just use
Mechanical Turk so they just show their
generated images to ten people ten
people the same image and the person
tells should tell whether it looks real
or not and then they average the results
because you just if you look at it you
really don't find any image that is
exactly equal to the image in the
training set there is also there is a
trained guns is not so easy there is a
mode collapse when a and can output
image the same image many times so but
there is a new paper message handgun
that actually avoid this now you can
train a generator it's not for we don't
use a discriminator for classification
it's a we want to drive this we still
haven't run but usually we want just to
generate positive examples because you
need to teach to train the generator
independently on positive examples to
generate positive and this is the usual
use of guns
yes so it just because it learned the
joint distribution of the data and in
just sample images from this
distribution this is what again does
okay thank you
[Applause]